In your book,
you're talking about companies who
are painkillers versus vitamins.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
>> Sure.
So there is kind of this religion about
vitamins versus painkillers.
What we teach MBAs today, or what
entrepreneurs hear when they go out and
try and raise venture capital, is that
they want to build a painkiller product.
We don't want to spend our time building
vitamins, we want to build painkillers.
Painkiller products are the kind
of products that customers can
tell you they need.
Stop my pain.
They have quantifiable markets, and
they're imminently monetizable.
Vitamins, on the other hand, that's
a kind of product that people say,
you know what,
I don't want to back that kind of
project within an enterprise, right.
Your boss or your PM will say,
no, I don't really.
That's a vitamin feature,
that's not something we need to build.
Let's build the painkillers.
>> Right.
>> So
a reason that a venture capitalist will
say, we're going to pass on that idea.
One of the reasons might be it just
doesn't seem like something really need.
So that's the current way of thinking.
I kind of challenge
that way of thinking,
because if you consider some of the
products that we've been talking about
that are very habit forming, like
Facebook, and Twitter, and Instagram,
and WhatsApp, these products
didn't start out as painkillers.
Nobody woke up 11 years ago, in the
middle of the night, two in the morning,
shouting I wish I could
update my status.
That never happened
before Facebook existed.
So these products that become
these painkillers over time,
they start out as vitamins.
They start out as nice to haves.
And they're frequently dismissed.
People say, oh, it's just a little toy.
It's not going to have a big impact.
Well, it turns out that
by creating habits,
by becoming these integral parts
of people's day to day lives.
They become pain killers
as they form these habits.
So today if Mark Zuckerberg said,
you know what we're going to
shut down Facebook.
I've made enough money.
I'm done,
people would have conniption fits right.
They would have a big problem.
>> Right.
>> All of a sudden this product that was
a toy and was just a vitamin has all
of a sudden become a painkiller.
>> And how do I know if my
idea is a painkiller or
a vitamin that could
become a painkiller?
>> Right, so it comes down to
figuring out if you have these hooks.
You have very little chance
of forming a habit without
having this hook built
into your product.
This four step process that takes
these pleasure-seeking behaviors and
becomes these pain killer products.